and I'm Cody Melchett hello everyone we
just saw Thor Ragnarok and great you
should we just saw that this is Tamara
just saw and Cody also just saw two as
well
Mythili was incredible it was so much
fun it's the most packed theater we've
been in for this series since Wonder
Woman the audience laughter and just
energy was incredible to be with we saw
it in IMAX
it was just oh I was hoping it would be
that good but I was not expecting it to
be that good yeah and it was it yeah it
exceeded expectations hopes yes ah so
good I I love Thor that the tank this is
this is my keychain he got these I
brought these
I love Thor and I've not save your
emails look I'm actually I'm moving you
know come on I have not really liked any
of the Thor movie Oh same I love Thor I
even loved the film character and I've
loved Thor the comic-book character for
a while a long time and it was so nice
to finally get a Thor movie that I
actually liked this was finally a Thor
movie that I love I haven't even seen
the second thorn that and Doctor Strange
are the two Marvel films that I haven't
seen this in different ways made me want
to see both of those yeah you know okay
so let's release this is gonna be
spoiler filled yeah say it I also have
clip-in bangs on because yeah I need a
haircut and I lost my beard trimmer
Leone spoilers right out of the gate
Hulk by great Oh welcome 1210 would Boop
again unfortunately you didn't see
anything else and I know I'm gonna be
honest there wish you did read a lot of
pecs
I'm gonna Peck some butt man
myself and it was pretty good for sure
but I was just curious you know you know
the only thing that was like ah like the
only thing that bums me out
not even bums me out it was like
literally the only thing I could find to
be upset about was that there's a giant
dog friend
and yeah he wasn't he was a great dog
friend and hella had him and in one
scene he was in the background and he
just kind of looks like just as like a
gigantic just regular dog and it wasn't
too scary it was only for like a few
seconds and yep I love giant dogs so it
was fine literally the only thing that
like effect that didn't look like
stellar - yeah and yeah a night and I
had a new piggie thing where there was a
weird line weird like she sets Thor up
for like a fro line and then repeats it
later but again that's that's me trying
to find something to say about this
movie other than I want to go watch it
again if we didn't have to film this and
I if I didn't have to pack I would have
been like I'm gonna just slip back in
see it again movie is more uh obsequious
of the galaxy than it is to Thor in the
sense of tone and so I'm gonna be a
little biased and I'm gonna be honest
about that I'm definitely skewed more
towards the guardians of the galaxy type
Doctor Strange and so this movie is in
my top three already but when it soldier
I enjoyed it I enjoyed it as a superhero
movie but not in my top and Marvel yeah
and so like that's the kind of movie I
want to see and so I know that like Thor
isn't that the original Thor isn't a bad
movie the second one but it's just not
this this was like this was guardians of
the galaxy turtle turn to eleven yes
Marvel was like oh you like this huh
here you go them just like shoved it in
your faces and it was like exhibit yeah
that's what I want I love this like
comedy on crack superhero film and give
me more give me all of that all the time
and that's what they did not one person
left when the credit started rolling not
one person and then they played a scene
then a few people trickled out and then
they played in
they're seeing everyone knows this day
which is so much fun I bet the people in
the film who do like I knew special
effects or like I don't know why me that
shots fired but like I bet they really
appreciate that because like people at
least see my name maybe yeah yeah I mean
what's you you you know Jeff Goldblum's
gonna come back like he has to yeah we
didn't get a Jeff Goldblum goodbye right
I gotta go bye bye he was amazing
it was great it was pure it was pure
uncut Jeff Goldblum yeah I am a huge fan
of the director Taika Waititi I was like
oh god I really hope this is really good
awesome yeah and it was and it was
amazing and I also did not know that he
was also going to be a character in it
who was perfect for him and also my
favorite character I think probably I
was expecting to love Jeff Goldblum the
most coming out of this and I think that
character might of be did Jeff Goldblum
out well I mean he was you in Blue Rock
form too sometimes some of it knows yeah
I hope I'm a little more competent it's
okay you know what right here gauntlet
down that's how you do Jar Jar Binks
right that is how you do Jar Jar Binks
right yeah yeah yeah if you want to put
just a random a random weird character
that's just gonna be like incredibly
awkward and silly for no reason and
undercut all emotional tension in every
moment yeah that's how you do it that's
a master class right there and Jar Jar
Binks I tell you what the Valkyrie was
my favorite character though yeah
Valkyrie did she have a name
yes yeah I'm bad with names
but I couldn't remember the rock guy's
name yeah yeah I remember Doug
Cate Blanchet was so good and so
fiercely sassy in a way that just made
my heart sing I would love to cosplay as
her she was just Kate I'm Kate flash
hello
look at my cheekbones
[Laughter]
that's what I would do it I would nail
it test tag hello look at my feet Birds
marvel I don't know how they're doing it
honestly but they've gotten really good
at building in everybody else I don't
mean like and I'm I'm somebody who gets
a little on edge about the concept of
like Universal movies where it's like
okay at a certain point these need to be
standalone films I cannot believe how
much I enjoyed the whole in this film I
remember yeah the trailers really did an
incredible job of pumping this film ah
but like hoax not my favorite of the
Avengers and I like hold a lot but I
don't know it's like that's an odd
pairing I suppose is the strongest
Avenger the one thing that confused me a
bit was that there were flirty sexual
tension moments between Bruce Banner and
Valkyrie and then Thor and Valkyrie
mm-hmm Jesus a strong independent woman
and she can flirt with everybody if she
wants to she could date all of them if
she wants damn it you're just on fire
with with like the the quote of the of
the episode and the last one it was like
listen I've learned that kitty cats do
it get out there it's incredible they've
set it up for a fourth whether that's
going to be a standalone or like tack it
on to another film you never know with
Marvel which is kind of exciting
yeah absolutely see this film you were
going to but you we're going to yeah
we're gonna you were gonna we knew it
this is Cody's last episode for a while
yeah cuz Cody is moving mm-hmm and has
deeply elevated quality of this show by
leaps and bounds as well so you don't
need anything cuz you're moving but I
was gonna make you a sign that said Cody
vulture on the internet some people like
you and give it to you as an award you
just felt like the worst comment someone
had ever posed
and razors edit laser etched into glass
yep
all right I can imagine that comment
being formulated in the mind and being
like typed out I got to do it I gotta
send it I have to know move on to the
next video that I'm gonna watch I have
to put this we met at an improv class
like yeah you were one of the first
friends I ever made in Chicago that was
the class where I learned that umbrellas
don't work near my apartment was walking
when the rain and was drenched in rain
that was also one of the things that
attracted Rachel and I to you Rachel T's
was also in the class because you had a
sword umbrella and we would this guy has
a sort of brother he's cool this has
been a little ass if if only because I
got to hang out with you more yeah yeah
[Laughter]
okay jokes jokes
alright well forever
[Laughter]
[Music]